another major storm today is threatening
to bring more rain and flooding to the
already soaked southeast at least six
states from the south up into the plains
face some risk of flooding parts of
Texas have been hit hard in Austin one
man died after falling into fast-moving
floodwaters officials in Houston tell us
they are gearing up for the next round
of severe weather
Mireya Villarreal is in Kingwood Texas
northeast of Houston where a good
morning well good morning right here
this is about as close as we can get to
a sinkhole that opened up right behind
me when a lot of that rain hit the
Houston area you can see there is
nothing left there a lot of it was swept
away by those floodwaters you know right
now a lot of that water in Kingwood has
receded after nearly 10 inches fell in
this area but as residents are just
starting to clean up they are worried
more water is on the way it was just
water everywhere across the Houston area
communities are recovering from three
days of rain and flooding in Kingwood
soaked furniture and soggy debris
blanket front yards after flood weary
residents spent the day clearing out
their waterlogged homes hundreds of
homes were impacted and even as
residents begin to dry out it's likely
severe storms will strike again later
today
the downpour sent a Creek over its banks
and onto this interstate in Kansas
shutting down nearly 40 miles of highway
it also inundated streets in this
neighborhood the water was so deep
David's coming into my basement last
night violent winds ripped through this
apartment complex in Arkansas four
people were injured
flash flooding also slammed that state
turning overpasses into water falls good
Samaritans pushed one woman off the road
after waters stalled her car
there are predictions at some parts of
Texas could reach up to an additional
six inches of rain over the next few
days and for people living here in
Kingwood they are very worried because
as I said this week this rain was more
than they expected and had experienced
even during Hurricane harvey Nora that's
a lot of rain but I a thank you